hey everybody Eric Trexler here with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast uh this is going to be a
solo episode and it's going to be all
about cardio for health and cardio for
weight management uh this is going to be
more of what I would call a synthesis
type episode where we are kind of
connecting topics and describing how
they fit together in kind of an
overarching cohesive way rather than
just drilling down into the very
granular details of a very specific
study or an extremely isolated topic so
it's going to be a wide-ranging episode
where we talk about uh the science
related to cardio and then the practical
application of cardio if you're
interested in improving your health or
you're interested in managing your
weight uh now like I said this is
another solo episode so I do want to
address a little update about the
ongoing strike by the stronger by
science podcast co-host Union uh now I
haven't had a lot of people asking me
about this because the episodes lately
have been the highest rated ever people
are just beating down my door trying to
advertise on the podcast trying to
invest in the podcast uh just five star
reviews everywhere but nonetheless I do
want to keep people updated so
we had reached a bit of a sticking point
the stronger by science podcast co-host
Union wanted a brand new Gulfstream
private jet uh initially I was reluctant
to uh to make that concession uh but
nonetheless I basically called in some
favors I met with some investors for a
round of fundraising and I was able to
secure the liquid capital capital that
would be necessary for us to go ahead
and purchase that jet
um
again I think the last few episodes The
Incredible ratings that have been coming
in all the fan mail I think that made
the investors very excited about the
opportunity uh but here's the issue I
thought that would resolve the matter
now that we had the funds secured to to
acquire that jet now the union is saying
that they want me to create an endowment
Fund in order to uh basically to cover
the operating expenses of that jet so
they want me to establish this endowment
Fund in order to cover fuel costs crew
Staffing and a variety of other
miscellaneous expenses uh so they want
me to create the fund they want me to
provide the initial Nest Egg investment
but they will not commit to any
transparency about how the fund operates
they want me to create and fund uh this
endowment but they want to keep me
completely in the dark about how it
operates uh and I have a number of
questions about why that's the case so
um that's a hard no for me we are at yet
another impasse in those negotiations
once again it is truly terrible what
that Union is doing to me and it's a
completely illegal strike and I'm sure
more updates will follow
now before I get into the content in
today's episode all about cardio uh just
a few reminders if you like the show and
you'd like to support it there are many
ways you could do that you could like
rate or subscribe wherever you get the
podcast you can join the stronger by
science email newsletter for free by
going to strongerbuyscience.com
newsletter you can check out our virtual
one-on-one coaching program at
strongerbyscience.com coaching you can
check out the mass research review at
strongerbyscience.com Mass you can check
out macro factor which is the diet app
that Greg and I co-developed with an
extremely talented team of colleagues
you can learn more about that at
macrofactorapp.com or just look for it
in the app stores and then finally
if you're looking for a discount on
supplements that are already very
reasonably priced you could go to
bulksupplements.com you could use the
discount code SBS pod SBS pod and that
will get you a five percent discount
from your entire order at
bulksupplements.com
all right so now moving on uh we're
talking about cardio for General Health
and for weight management and usually
when people are adding cardio we're
talking about weight loss in terms of
weight management now this episode is
not going to be an in-depth look at
performance oriented endurance training
we're not going to cover you know
periodizing your running so that you can
hit a PR at your at your next marathon
uh that that's a wonderful goal to have
it's just not the focus of this episode
we're going to be taking a comprehensive
look at basically everything you need to
know start to finish about the
relationship between physical activity
General Health and weight management and
before we get into the details I think
it's important to cover what I would
call the General taxonomy of physical
activity because physical activity can
take a lot of different forms and it's
kind of helpful to get a lay of the land
and map out how these different concepts
fit together or so
we've got this big umbrella that we call
physical activity
and we can divide that into kind of it
creates like a bifurcated path where we
could divide that into two broader
categories
the first category would be non-exercise
physical activity okay so this is
physical activity that occurs throughout
the day but it is not structured
exercise right so uh when if you're for
example a college student and you're
walking from your dorm to your class
maybe it's a 15 20 minute walk that's
physical activity but you didn't set out
to do exercise there you basically are
just ambulating because you need to get
somewhere and there are all sorts of
physical activities we do throughout the
day that are not structured exercise uh
you go get the mail you go mow the lawn
you do housework that involves being on
your feet and moving around all of these
things are physical activity but they
are not what we would call structured
exercise so we can divide physical
activity into non-exercise physical
activity and then the second category
would be structured exercise now within
structured exercise we can break that
down even further of course there is
resistance type exercise and then we
have cardio type exercise so there's a
lot of different terminology that's used
depending on the context sometimes
people say cardio sometimes they say
aerobic exercise sometimes they say
endurance training
and ultimately uh some of these terms
become less appropriate in certain
contexts you know so you could talk
about this General category of cap of
cardio and say well we're going to call
it aerobic training but what about when
we do higher intensity forms it's really
more anaerobic that aerobic in that
context or you could say we're going to
call it endurance training but what
about when you're doing Sprint type
exercise and you're really more training
for Sprint related power outcome rather
than endurance per se so these terms
sometimes they just don't fit as well
depending on the context so I'm just
going to use the overarching term cardio
and what we're talking about there is
structured exercise that is not
resistance training and generally falls
under the category of what we would
consider aerobic exercise endurance
exercise Sprint type exercise you get
the idea so within cardio we can break
that down further into two categories
one would be interval training and the
other would be steady state training so
within interval training we could talk
about sit or Sprint interval training
and that is kind of the highest
intensity form of interval training
where each work bout you know with
interval training obviously you're going
to have intervals of work and intervals
of rest that kind of cycle back and
forth with Sprint interval training
we're talking about a maximal intensity
Sprint during those work intervals so
that is kind of the highest intensity
form of cardio there's also high
intensity interval training and you
could argue that Sprint interval
training is kind of a subtype of high
intensity interval training but with
high intensity interval training we have
a little bit more flexibility
there are many applications of high
intensity interval training that are not
actually maximal Sprints in terms of
intensity usually with high intensity
interval training you're trying to get
your heart rate up to at least 85
percent of the maximal value but you
might find some inner some high
intensity interval training protocols uh
where you know heart rate is still
getting into that range above 85 percent
of Max but but you certainly wouldn't
call it a maximal intensity Sprint okay
so we can kind of establish a a spectrum
of intensities when it comes to cardio
with interval training Sprint interval
training is the highest intensity but
we've also got high intensity interval
training which could theoretically be a
little bit lower in intensity
then we can look over at steady state
training Options under this cardio
umbrella so we've got moderate intensity
steady state training where Max where
heart rate is we're trying to get it to
somewhere between 70 to 84 percent of
Maximum and then there's low intensity
steady state uh which is basically
anything below 70 percent of Max heart
rate but generally speaking we're trying
to get it somewhere between 50 to 69
percent of Max heart rate so again when
we look at a physical activity in
general we can focus in on structured
exercise and then within that we can
focus in on cardio and Under the
Umbrella of cardio we've got this
spectrum of intensities
Sprint interval training high intensity
interval training moderate intensity
steady state and then low intensity
steady state and as you can imagine
there is an inverse relationship when we
look at the relationship between
intensity and duration so Sprint
interval training your actual work
intervals are going to be extremely
short in duration uh you know usually
it's only 10 15 30 seconds when we're
talking about Sprint interval training
when we talk about low intensity steady
state I mean this could be going for you
know a a three hour hike you know it
could be very very long duration because
of the low intensity so now we've got an
idea of this taxonomy
and we're going to get into structured
cardio but I want to begin by focusing
on that whole other side of the taxonomy
non-exercise physical activity uh and
the goal here you know we're going to
talk about non-exercise physical
activity specifically as it pertains to
just General Health rather than weight
management per se and when we look at
the goal of non-exercise physical
activity I mean some of it is just
activities of daily living that we have
to do in order to keep our life moving
you know we go we go check the mail we
go to work things like that uh mow the
lawn so it doesn't become overgrown you
get the idea but sometimes we will
intentionally include some of this
non-exercise physical activity uh for
the goal of just improving General
Health so we might not be saying I'm
going to you know go to the gym for an
hour to do cardio
but we might incorporate some physical
activity into our day in ways that
doesn't really reflect what we would
consider structured exercise so the
benefits of incorporating some of this
physical activity
um one of the the benefits is that we
have the opportunity to break up long
periods of sedentary time and we have
the opportunity to replace some of our
sedentary time with active time right so
instead of being at your desk for eight
or nine hours straight without any
movement the idea is if we can
incorporate some non-exercise physical
activity throughout the day maybe during
your lunch break at work we can break up
this large chunk of sedentary time and
then in our leisure time if we replace
you know watching television or you know
uh you know playing a video game
something like that nothing wrong with
watching television playing video games
but if we can replace some of that with
more active Leisure Time activities
there might be some benefit it's and so
when it comes to the overall health
benefits of physical activity they are
obviously numerous so there's a great
paper by Pearson colleagues I'll link it
in the show notes they talk about
physical activity guidelines but they
also talk about just the general
benefits of physical activity so uh
increasing physical activity can lead to
lower risk of cardiovascular disease
hypertension type 2 diabetes
several different cancers all cause
mortality a lot of times when people
become more physically active we'll see
an improvement in their blood lipid
profile we'll see reduced anxiety
symptoms lower risk of depression
improved sleep improve cognition
physical activity the um the benefits
really are very impressive very
extensive very wide ranging in terms of
the number of different elements of
Health that can be impacted by physical
activity
so I probably don't have to do a lot of
work if you're listening to the stronger
by science podcast you probably have a
general appreciation for the fact that
physical activity does promote health
and wellness but what I want to talk
about here are a few ways to uh increase
your physical activity without
necessarily committing to a cardio
program or what we would typically call
or typically associate with a structured
exercise program so one of the ways that
we can increase physical activity again
with the goal being to break up
sedentary time and increase the time
that we spend each day doing physical
activity one method is by using uh a
term that's kind of new in the
literature it kind of popped up within
the last decade or two
but the term is exercise snacks and I
know the name is kind of cheesy but the
concept is legit and it is rooted in
some pretty good science so exercise
snacks you know we think of a snack as
being kind of a just a little nibble
rather than a big extensive meal uh it's
the same kind of thing an exercise snack
is an extremely small portion of
exercise uh that that typically is going
to be done with high frequency at
regular intervals throughout the day so
rather than focusing you know with a
typical structured exercise program we
often focus on how much activity we are
accumulating uh either in the exercise
bout or across the day with exercise
snacks we're really focusing on the
frequency and the timing of physical
activity so rather than saying oh I need
to do an extra 45 minutes of physical
activity today the focus is
how am I going to break up my sedentary
time throughout the day and so it's
thought you know you really focus on uh
when throughout the day you're going to
basically insert these little exercise
snacks so there's a really nice review
by Islam and colleagues that was
published in 2022 I'm going to link it
in the show notes but generally speaking
but they give a great overview of
exercise snacks what we're talking about
are very short bouts of vigorous
exercise that's going to be repeated
several times throughout the day uh
usually in pretty regular intervals and
the purpose is very specifically to
disrupt prolonged periods of sedentary
time
so for example
an exercise Knack could involve less
than one cumulative minute of exercise
throughout the day and so that would
look like you know taking several like
10 second or 15 second exercise bouts
that are kind of distributed evenly
throughout your work day for example now
when we talk about doing an interval
type approach to physical activity with
less than a minute of cumulative
exercise what that means is there's
going to be a big emphasis on efficiency
and a big emphasis on intensity
so if you look at some of the literature
on exercise snacks usually a perceived
effort is is well above a five on a 10
point scale so people are doing you know
seven out of ten eight out of ten nine
out of ten uh in terms of their
perceived intensity level so it you get
the idea here it is regular intervals a
very brief physical activity done uh
with a relatively high level of
intensity now I've given some guidelines
about cumulative exercise totals being
less than a minute uh I've given some
guidelines about you know the relative
intensity of these efforts but I think
it's
um important not to get too bogged down
in the details uh there there's no
specific rule book that you have to
follow when it comes to applying the
concept of exercise snacks
the general premise is very very simple
and you know just staying in line with
the general premise is enough you don't
have to follow some perfect protocol so
the idea is you know if you have an
eight-hour work day let's say you work
in a conventional office building eight
hour work day you might say every two
hours so we're gonna have four total
intervals or you know you can allocate
them however you see fit based on your
daily schedule but let's say every
couple hours ish we're gonna do a 15
second bout of exercise so maybe you
have the opportunity depending on your
work environment and your work culture
perhaps you can make your way over to
the stairwell
and say I'm going to do a 15 second bout
where I just run up the stairs and just
cover as many flights as I can in 15
seconds or as many steps as I can in 15
seconds so you just walk over to the
stairwell very quickly you know a 15
second burst of exercise you know walk
or even run up the stairs for 15 seconds
and that that is your exercise snack and
then you go back to work uh you know
work for another hour and a half two
hours go back to the stairwell do it
again and so you can see how you know if
you do that four times we're only
talking about approximately a minute of
exercise but we are breaking up those
longer chunks of you know eight or nine
hours of sedentary time we're breaking
that up with these regular intervals so
uh in the interest of practical
application like I said you don't need
to focus too much on the exact intensity
the exact duration the general premises
if you're looking at a schedule for your
day and you say I might legitimately be
seated for like eight hours straight
here or you know two sections uh two
intervals where you're just sitting for
four hours straight you might want to go
in and break that up with some activity
and in the interest of being practical
there are a lot of viable modalities
that can be done
you know in a typical workplace or in a
lot of different settings so it could be
stair climbing jumping jacks really any
body weight calisthenic exercises
there's a lot of options here and of
course the simplest one is just doing a
brisk walk in the hallway or a brisk
walk in the parking lot for just a short
period of time and so when we look at
the preliminary evidence in this area
like I said really great review paper by
Islam and colleagues in 2022
when we look at the research here when
we see uh you know these exercise snacks
generally speaking when they're
implemented relatively frequently
throughout the day when they're
implemented with sufficient intensity
there are studies indicating that they
do confer some health benefits related
to cardiorespiratory Fitness levels
cardiometabolic risk factors and
Vascular Health in general so exercise
snacks very very simple if you were just
interested in General Health rather than
weight management and saying how do I
make physical activity part of my day
exercise snacks would be one option
another method that's very simple and
very popular is simply tracking your
step counts so again this is not doing a
structured walking program necessarily
but we're just focusing on am I getting
enough steps throughout the day in order
to support in order to support overall
health and wellness and so this is the
complete opposite of I wouldn't say
complete opposite but it's a very
different concept than exercise snacks
because rather than focusing on the
frequency and the timing of where we're
putting these steps you know exercise
snacks like I said very very much
focused on frequency and timing if we're
just trying to track our step count the
focus now is on the cumulative amount of
physical activity throughout the day and
we're using step counts as a proxy to
get an idea of our overall activity
level because theoretically on a day
where we have higher step counts that
means that we're spending more time up
on our feet being active ambulating
moving around
Etc so step counts very straightforward
not going to spend a lot of time
belaboring the point there but a
question that comes up a lot is well how
many steps is actually enough for
supporting General Health and Wellness
there is a paper by Jay Eddie and
colleagues where they found a linear
dose response relationship where more
steps was associated with lower
mortality risk and they've found that
that linear dose response relationship
went all the way up to about 17 000
steps per day and at that point the the
data set just becomes very sparse there
aren't that many folks in studies that
are available
who are routinely getting above that so
I I if I'm remembering correctly from
the figure in the paper it's not that
they found that benefits stopped at 17
000 steps it was more that there was
just a limitation of how much data they
had Beyond 17 000 steps a day uh but
there are some papers that suggest
there's a slightly more nuanced
relationship rather than just saying
more is better so there is a paper by
paluke and colleagues where they found
that mortality related benefits were
basically maximized at about eight to
ten thousand steps per day for
individuals who are under the age of 60
and then for individuals who are 60 or
older they found that some of these
mortality related benefits were actually
maximized at a lower number which was
about six to eight thousand steps per
day so by looking at these two studies
we get a general understanding of if
we're trying to use step count as a
proxy for physical activity and we're
trying to promote Health and Wellness
we get an idea of what kind of numbers
we should be shooting for so uh if
you're 60 and older probably shooting
for a lower number than people who are
under the age of 60
um and what we're looking at is getting
up into that range of eight thousand ten
thousand twelve thousand steps per day
with the general understanding that more
is broadly better but there's probably a
point at which we start to see
diminishing returns so
um getting up into that eight ten twelve
thousand step per day range seems like a
really good idea whether or not there
are extra benefits to be had Beyond you
know getting into you know fourteen
thousand sixteen thousand that becomes a
little bit more debatable
um and I think we can intuitively assume
that there is some point at which the
return on investment gets smaller and
smaller as you get into those higher
ranges now you might be looking at those
numbers and looking at your smartphone
or your Fitbit or whatever you use to
track your steps and you might be saying
I am not even close to those ranges how
am I going to get from where I'm at to
ten thousand or twelve thousand steps
per day and my recommendation would be
to do it slowly and incrementally Okay
so
a really uh practical way to do that is
by increasing your daily step goal by
500 to a thousand steps every couple of
weeks or every few weeks and just kind
of slowly work yourself into the
intended range and what I would
encourage you to do is when you look at
this range if getting to 12 000 steps
per day seems completely unfeasible at
this point in time aim for six thousand
aim for eight thousand you know set a
lower boundary goal get there make it a
habit and then you can reassess whether
or not it would be feasible to get from
eight thousand to ten thousand or from
ten thousand to twelve thousand uh you
know you want to work your way
incrementally so that it doesn't seem
like a completely daunting and
unfeasible task now we've got exercise
snacks we could rely on step counts if
we're trying to increase physical
activity to support General Health and
well-being but there is a third method
we could lean on here
and the third method is a little bit
more nuanced it requires a little bit
more attention a little bit more
planning and in some cases it does start
to blur the lines between non-exercise
physical activity and structured
exercise there's a level of planning
here
um at a level of focusing on the dose
and the duration and things like that
where we are starting to blur the line
and this is getting pretty close to
structured exercise depending on how you
apply it so uh the third method here is
just aiming to meet the general physical
activity guidelines that are provided by
governing institutions and medical
organizations so I mentioned a PRC a
paper by Pearson colleagues from 2018
which explains a pretty simple physical
activity guidelines I believe it was in
the Journal of the American Medical
Association if memory serves but when I
put the link in the show notes we'll see
if my memory is correct there but the
guidelines that they'll that they lay
out
basically suggests that you aim for 150
to 300 weekly minutes of exercise at a
moderate intensity and when they talk
about moderate intensity they're talking
about moderate net levels which would be
somewhere between 3.0 and 5.9 Mets and a
met is a unit uh that that it stands for
metabolic equivalent I guess I should
say it's short for metabolic equivalent
and Mets uh basically are are a fairly
simple interchangeable way of
quantifying energy expenditure more
broadly and so if we talk about doing
exercise at a low met level versus a
high Met level we're basically getting a
proxy for exercise intensity and
expenditure that occurs during that
exercise
so one metabolic equivalent is basically
our energy expenditure per unit time at
rest and so when we talk about using
meds we're basically just in a relative
events scaling things up from the
resting value in terms of our energy
expenditure so
these guidelines like I said they
recommend 150 to 300 weekly minutes of
physical activity at moderate net levels
between 3.0 and 5.9 Mets or they
recommend getting 75 to 150 weekly
minutes of physical activity at what
they call vigorous net levels and that
would be a met value above 6.0 or I
should say equal to or greater than 6.0
or of course you could combine the two
categories so you could do a mixture of
moderate and vigorous physical activity
based on these met levels you can kind
of mix and match so rather than doing
150 minutes of moderate activity or
doing 75 of vigorous activity you could
do a combination of both and kind of mix
them together now one thing I want to
reiterate here is that when you hear 75
minutes of vigorous activity that
doesn't mean 75 minutes of sprinting
okay so when we talk about net levels
vigorous exercise is probably a lot
lower intensity than you're thinking a
lot of times athletes hear vigorous
intensity or people who are really Avid
Fitness enthusiasts and they say well
that's 75 to 150 minutes is kind of a
lot when we think about doing like
Sprint interval training or something
like that that's not what these
guidelines are calling for so for
example a net level of three which gets
you into the bottom range of of moderate
activity that would be walking at a very
very comfortable pace of 2.5 miles per
hour on a level surface so just walking
on a flat treadmill or walking down the
street 2.5 miles per hour for a lot of
folks is an extremely comfortable very
leisurely walking pace so it's by no
means a Brisk power walk for most folks
but I understand you know people have
very different walking speeds so I don't
mean to be
um don't mean to convey any sense of
Judge management if 2.5 miles per hour
is is a relatively vigorous walking pace
for you but generally speaking a lot of
folks can walk at 2.5 miles an hour and
not consider it to be a particularly
vigorous
um intensity for their walking uh to
give another example a met level of 3.8
is associated with raking the leaves in
your lawn with a moderate level of of
effort there's also a net level of 3.3
associated with just general uh kitchen
activity so cooking washing dishes
cleaning up in the kitchen so you can
see that some of these activities of
daily living put us well into the
moderate range another example is a met
level of five is associated with mowing
your lawn and a met level of six is
associated with shoveling snow by hand
with a shovel if you get up to walking
at 4.5 miles per hour that's usually a
very brisk walking pace now you're
actually getting into a level that's
about seven which is is already into the
vigorous category and like I said we're
talking about walking here you know so
you can actually hit the um
when we talk about moderate versus
vigorous ferment levels you can get into
the vigorous category without actually
breaking into a jog you know if you're
walking briskly at 4.5 miles per hour
you are above that um vigorous threshold
which is six Mets so walking at 4.5
miles an hour is all the way into seven
Mets even on a flat surface with no
incline when we talk about kind of
structured exercise just to kind of uh
give a perspective of where where Things
Fall with these met levels uh stair
climbing at a very slow pace would be
about four bets pretty vigorous
resistance training would be about six
Mets running at four miles an hour
probably about six minutes rowing at 100
watts would be about seven minutes doing
calisthenics like you know push-ups
setups jumping jacks pull-ups you know
kind of uh body weight circuit training
you might be looking at a met level up
around eight uh now of course these are
are rough estimates you might be
wondering where did these all come from
and they come from a compendium of
physical activities the last time it was
updated I believe was 2011 by Ainsworth
and colleagues
so if you want to get an idea of
different met levels for different types
of physical activity or even structured
exercises I'm going to put a link in the
show notes to a really comprehensive
website that basically is is very
searchable so you can search this
compendium of physical activities I've
mentioned on the show before it has well
over 800 entries for different physical
activities and different types of
structured exercise but what you can do
is you can say okay I see these physical
activity guidelines by Piercy and
colleagues I see the duration that's
recommended and the associated met
ranges in terms of intensity now I'm
going to go through the compendium of
physical activities and just kind of
tabulate am I meeting these guidelines
already and if not then you might
consider how you might incorporate some
physical activity or you know some
actual structured exercise in order to
get into the ranges that are recommended
for General Health and Wellness so we've
got the use three different strategies
for implementing non-exercise physical
activity or little bouts of structured
exercise in order to use cardio use
physical activity to support General
Health and General Wellness so that
stuff's pretty simple we can do exercise
snacks we can aim for a daily step count
and use that as a proxy for physical
activity or we can actually dig a little
deeper and look at some of these
guidelines tabulate our met values
throughout the week or throughout the
day and you know perhaps make some
adjustments to get into those
recommended physical activity ranges
at this point we are going to shift the
the episode here and shift the focus to
weight management and more specifically
using cardio to strategically facilitate
fat loss while we talk about weight
management now there are many benefits
of cardio type exercise for fat loss
so first of all uh and when I say fat
loss I I think I should extrapolate that
to say just body composition in general
so maintaining fat free Mass losing fat
Mass losing weight these kind of all
fall under the weight management
umbrella
there are many benefits like I said of
exercise for body composition and fat
loss first of all if you're quite
inactive at Baseline it is possible that
some recomping may occur so there there
have been meta-analyzes indicating that
with previously untrained people even
some pretty basic cardio interventions
can lead to an increase in fat free Mass
I've even seen some interventions where
a walking program led to an increase in
lean body mass and most likely lower
body lean mass just from using the leg
musculature more than the individuals
had been using it previously so low
intensity cardio may involve some
recomping by by increasing uh you know
fat-free mass of the lower extremities
but there's also some interventions with
high intensity or Sprint interval
training where you'll see you know some
some actually pretty substantial
improvements in lower lower body
muscularity because there are so many
high intensity forceful muscular
contractions occurring so with with
exercise one of the reasons to include
it in a weight loss or Weight Management
program is you might actually experience
some recomposition from doing relatively
intense forms of cardio number two
another benefit of exercise when it
comes to weight management is that if
your Baseline physical activity level is
low and you start doing more exercise
more physical activity this can help
recouple your appetite to match your
energy expenditure more effectively and
it can do it in a way that reduces the
likelihood of passive overeating so
there's been some really cool research
indicating that there is this very
non-linear relationship between uh
between appetite or satiety control and
uh physical activity
so when we look at folks who have a very
low level of Baseline physical activity
we see that their appetite is not very
effectively matched to their activity
level so if you're very very sedentary
there can sometimes be this increase in
appetite such that you are eating for
reasons that are not directly matched to
your energy expenditure and a lot of
times this leads to passive over
consumption of calories and what we'll
see in the research is as people start
to do more physical activity this
relationship between appetite and energy
expenditure becomes more tightly linked
and so we'll see that there's kind of a
correction of appetite that occurs when
you go from low physical activity levels
to moderate or high physical activity
levels and so there is some evidence
suggesting that if physical activity is
very very low at Baseline you might have
a relatively High appetite level that is
disproportionate to your energy expense
manager and you can effectively correct
that mismatch by doing some more
physical activity
now uh that leads to a good question
what about appetite for people who
already have a high physical activity
level at Baseline so if your Baseline
physical activity level is very low and
you increase physical activity we might
see that your appetite becomes more
tightly controlled better regulated uh
and so we might see a passive reduction
in overeating but if you're already
pretty active at Baseline and you
increase your physical activity level
what happens with appetite the answer is
a bit complicated so exercise does seem
to acutely but transiently suppress
appetite as long as the intensity level
is high enough so you can think about
doing a really hard Sprint workout
within 30 minutes an hour after that a
lot of folks mention that they really
just don't want to eat or in some cases
they can't even think of stomaching a
meal after a really intense bout of
exercise but obviously that dissipates
that Fades throughout the day when we
talk about the overall broader impact on
appetite
when someone goes from moderate or high
physical activity levels to even higher
levels of physical activity uh when you
look at reviews on the topic the
evidence is very mixed and it looks like
there's a pretty significant degree of
variation from person to person from
study to study and unfortunately
researchers to the best of my knowledge
haven't really conclusively identified
the exact characteristics that would
explain or fully elucidate the variation
that's seen in the literature so some
folks seem to notice that when they ramp
up their physical activity level
appetite is either unchanged or even
goes down a little bit other folks
notice that when they start ramping up
their physical activity they almost feel
like there's a disproportionate level of
appetite and hunger relative to their
energy expenditure so that's an area
where we need a lot more research but it
does seem to be pretty uh pretty well
established that going from very low
activity to moderate activity usually
leads to a correction in appetite levels
in a way that reduces unintended
overeating
now a third benefit of exercise here
when it comes to facilitating weight
management is that exercise increases
total daily energy expenditure of course
if we want to lose fat we need to create
a caloric deficit and there are two
levers that we can pull if we're trying
to create a caloric deficit we can
increase our daily energy expenditure or
we can reduce our daily energy intake so
exercise by increasing total daily
energy expenditure can directly
facilitate fat loss through the creation
or the establishment or the maintenance
of an energy deficit and then number
four when we look at the benefits of
exercise and physical activity for
weight management
there's a very consistent finding that
pops up in the literature again and
again and again and that is high
physical activity levels seem to be a
very reliable predictor of successful
long-term maintenance of weight loss so
for the people who are able to lose
weight and maintain it for a long period
of time usually the folks who really
Thrive and really succeed in the long
run with maintaining their weight loss
are the folks who maintain a high level
of physical activity
thank you
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
now that stuff all sounds great but
there is a problem that we've discussed
previously on the show and the problem
is as follows
exercise requires a pretty big
investment when it comes to time and
just the physical effort that goes into
it and unfortunately exercise typically
impacts weight loss far less than we
would expect it to intuitively and far
less than we would even mathematically
predict and so when we talk about
exercise as a tool for weight loss or
Weight Management it's it's a bit of an
uphill battle because you will talk to
folks who say yeah I tried to increase
my exercise and I just didn't lose much
weight at all or I lost way less weight
than I expected and the effort that got
put into it didn't really seem to be
matched by the things I was getting out
of those efforts you know there was a
mismatch between the investment and the
return on the investment that was not
favorable and so to to look at that more
closely we can lean on a study by Broski
and colleagues Dr Eric Helms reviewed it
in the Mass research review when it came
out within the past year or two
and basically
this paper by Broski and colleagues
which I'll link in the show notes it was
a sub analysis from a larger study where
they were looking at you know how
different doses of cardio type exercise
would impact weight loss in a
longitudinal setting so it was kind of a
an extended trial where they were
looking at the effects of weight loss at
different levels or the effects of
physical activity at different cardio
doses in order to see how it would
impact weight loss over time so there
was one group that was doing about 800
to a thousand calories
of additional exercise per week and
there was another group that was doing
about 2 000 to 2500 calories per week of
extra aerobic exercise so they had these
two different Doses and what they found
was you know at the end of this study
they brought participants into a
metabolic chamber to measure their uh
their 24-hour energy energy expenditure
in resting conditions okay so it's
important to recognize the number I'm
about to say here does not incorporate
the physical activity or the cardio that
they were doing during the trial this
was just looking at like
now that you've been doing all this
cardio what is your 24 hour energy
expenditure look like if we put you in
this tiny little room and just measure
it for 24 hours what they found was that
24-hour energy expenditure or daily
energy expenditure dropped by about four
percent in the group that was doing the
higher dose of cardio now of course they
were not exercising in the chamber so if
they had added in the expenditure from
their cardio it it's not like there was
this huge reduction in total energy
expenditure across the board this was
just looking at resting elements of
energy expenditure but what the study
reinforced was a pretty consistent
finding which is that when we increase
you know structured exercise or
intentional physical activity we can
increase our energy expenditure in a way
that still has a net increase in total
daily energy expenditure however
it's not as big as we would expect we
see that there are reductions in other
non-activity areas of energy expenditure
that partially offset some of these
calories that were burning during
exercise and so when you look at the
totality of the literature when it comes
to using exercise alone as a weight loss
intervention uh exercise is only going
to cause in most cases about 20 to 50
percent of the weight loss that you
would expect based on the caloric
estimate of energy expenditure so to
state that differently it's going to
cost 50 to 80 percent less weight loss
than you had expected from this exercise
intervention and that's not great you
know you don't want to tell people you
know hey we're going to do this uh this
exercise intervention is going to take
some time it's going to take some effort
and the amount of weight loss you're
anticipating we're only going to get a
quarter or maybe half of that when it's
all said and done uh so so that's a big
challenge when it comes to helping
people use exercise as part of their
weight management strategy the return on
investment is like I said only a quarter
to a half of what we would expect and
there's two major reasons for that so
like I said
we can look at these indices of resting
energy expenditure and say okay it's
clear that when people are doing all
this cardio there's kind of an Adaptive
reduction that partially but not fully
offsets some of these increases in total
daily energy expenditure so that's part
of it another part of it is that some
folks do seem to passively eat more when
they exercise not necessarily in a
disproportionate amount relatively to
the amount of exercise they're doing but
there are some folks where you know
their appetite is really tightly
calibrated to their activity level so if
you say okay do an extra 100 calories
per day of exercise if they're not also
on a structured diet plan they might
just naturally eat an extra 100 calories
of food every day and so they are doing
this this exercise and they are
increasing their energy expenditure but
their appetite is adapting in a way that
just kind of replaces the calories that
are being burned so there there are two
different things that are making weight
loss
like I said are that are making exercise
about 50 to 80 percent less effective
than we would expect for weight loss
just in numerical terms one is
fluctuations in energy intake as a
response to exercise and the other is
adaptive reductions in resting energy
expenditure and so that brings me to uh
kind of a a more focused conversation or
a more focused discussion of exercise
energy compensation uh this this idea
that as we do more physical activity we
will see reductions in non-activity
elements of daily energy expenditure
this is something we've talked about on
the show many times because it's a very
active area of research frankly I would
say it's one of the more exciting areas
of research right now when it comes to
applied metabolism
there is so much interesting research
coming out in this area and it's coming
out at a very rapid rate
um you know it's it's something that got
rolling a lot of interest started to
develop in this uh this idea
I would say kind of got reinvigorated
around 2016 give or take and then just
in the last two years it has really
picked up quite rapidly uh but looking
at it uh just in a nutshell we're
talking about exercise energy
compensation or compensating for the
calories burned during exercise and this
relates to the constrained total energy
expenditure model which uh I believe
Herman Ponce came up with it if not he
has championed the concept and really
become the face of the concept I believe
he developed the model in its initial uh
form so Dr Herman ponser author of the
book Burn which has become very very
popular he's done a lot of work in this
area and his initial work was related to
a very interesting set of preliminary
observations which was if you if you
compare sedentary people in very
industrialized environments
if you compare those folks to people in
modern day hunter-gatherer environments
where physical activity levels are
extremely high uh despite these
different Lifestyles despite these
different uh durations spent doing
physical activity uh total daily energy
expenditure is surprisingly similar when
you compare these very very different
groups of people with very very
different physical activity levels and
so the question was why isn't total
daily total daily energy expenditure
dramatically higher in these
hunter-gatherer environments where
people are doing so much more physical
activity than folks who are relatively
sedentary and living in more
industrialized environments and
ultimately this whole body of research
has led toward the conclusion that
humans do seem to compensate for some of
the energy burned during exercise by
experiencing adaptive reductions in
resting compound components of energy
expenditure so in other words if you're
burning more calories through physical
activity it's very likely that you'll be
be burning fewer calories while you are
resting
now I mentioned that this is
part of what we call the constrained
total energy expenditure model and that
means that this becomes much more
important when physical activity levels
get very very very high the idea is that
there is an upper limit on total energy
expenditure that is constrained so that
humans don't basically push them still
push themselves into you know a
threatening situation where starvation
is imminent just because they're highly
active and if you want to get really
theoretical in big picture and kind of
frame it in evolutionary terms it makes
sense so if we you know
spent the majority of our evolutionary
history being hunter-gatherers that
would mean that we probably have an
increase in physical activity when uh
when we really need to be cranking up
our our uh investment in gathering uh
nutritional resources right so we
certainly don't want to have mechanisms
built in where the more active we are
the closer we get to starvation we would
like to have some cap on that so that we
have the ability to go out and hunt and
gather food when we really need it so
from an evolutionary perspective there
are a number of different reasons that
it would be highly protective to have
some some upper limit on total energy
expenditure so that we don't have to
just gather really infeasible or
unfeasible amounts of food in order to
keep ourselves alive and keep ourselves
from starving so just in order to gather
enough resources to maintain uh
biological viability and not starve to
death it would be very advantageous to
have some upper cap on total energy
expenditure now the average magnitude of
compensation that we see
is based on the the best evidence
available around 30 percent of
compensation so what that means is if
you do a hundred calories worth of
exercise total daily energy expenditure
only goes up by 70 calories you've
compensated 30 percent which means 30 of
those 100 calories have been uh made up
for by reductions in resting energy
expenditure so again if you thought you
were increasing your total daily energy
expenditure by 200 calories by doing
extra exercise you're probably only
going to get about 70 percent of the
anticipated increase in total daily
energy expenditure you're probably going
to compensate for the other 30 percent
um I should mention
this relationship is not linear and it
seems to differ quite a bit from person
to person so 30 percent is kind of the
average value
but when we look at the research we see
that there are plenty of folks who seem
to be only experiencing about 10
compensation so they're getting 90
percent of the investment that they're
putting in uh in terms of increasing
total daily energy expenditure and then
we also see
that uh there are plenty of folks who
are experiencing up to 50 energy
compensation so they're only getting 50
percent of their return on investment
when it comes to investing exercise for
the outcome of increasing total daily
energy expenditure so uh average is
around 30 compensation but it varies a
lot most people find themselves
somewhere between 10 and 50 10 and 50
percent compensation and there are a few
factors that have been identified when
we try to actually explain
why are some people compensating more
than others uh one and the most
important one in my opinion
is just total physical activity level
like I said the idea with this model is
not that everyone has the same total
daily energy expenditure it's that there
is an upper limit that that where we
start to see energy expenditure getting
capped or constrained so what that means
is when we look at the research when
someone is starting with a very low
physical activity level
very very low total daily energy
expenditure if they increase their
physical activity a little bit and they
move their expenditure up but it's still
quite low in absolute terms we don't
really see a lot of compensation they
are not threatening that upper limit of
human energy expenditure so when we look
at low levels of activity and low levels
of total energy expenditure we really
don't see a lot of compensation when we
see people who are already very active
and burning a ton of calories when those
folks increase their energy or their
their physical activity we see much
higher levels of compensation because
they are actually bumping up near that
area where you know it seems like there
are some kind of corrective forces from
a biological perspective that are trying
to constrain or cap this upper limit of
total energy expenditure so the
relationship is extremely non-linear we
see very minimal uh extra size energy
compensation for people with low
activity level low energy expenditure
but we see a very high level of
compensation
for people who are doing a ton of
physical activity and already have
extremely high total daily energy
expenditure uh another factor that comes
into play when it comes to the level of
compensation that someone experiences
would be energy balance there's been
some really fascinating research
indicating that someone who is in an
energy deficit so someone who is for
example doing an intentional weight loss
program they seem to experience a higher
degree of compensation compared to
someone who is in neutral energy balance
or someone who is in an energy Surplus
which generally makes sense
if the goal here is to essentially
conserve resources when someone is
already in an energy deficit uh you know
all of the biological cues pertaining to
energy availability are starting to
convey some warning signs you know
saying hey it looks like energy is a bit
scarce here we might want to be very
conservative about how we are allocating
energy expenditure and we might want to
cap it if we can and so what we see here
is that when people are already in an
energy deficit and perceived energy
availability is already low if they
increase their physical activity they
seem to have a higher level of energy
compensation and so that shows us
that there seems to be a convergence
here of two different topics one is
exercise energy compensation uh and the
other is just good old-fashioned
metabolic adaptation when energy level
is low uh or when energy availability is
low we have these conservation
mechanisms to reduce energy expenditure
and it seems like when we are doing more
exercise exercise energy compensation is
one of many levers that we can pull
during an energy deficit just just to
try to make sure that we are not
um you know getting into a spot
physiologically where we have a
critically low level of energy
availability so when we are dieting we
experience metabolic adaptation to some
extent you know cardio aside the body is
trying to down regulate energy
expenditure to save energy and
ultimately prevent starvation
and so it makes sense that if we then
introduce and and uh an increase in
physical activity or cardio exercise we
see that that is yet another area where
during an energy deficit the body is
going to try to essentially limit the
impact on energy expenditure so without
question we see more exercise energy
compensation in people who are already
exercising a ton and have a high level
of energy expenditure we also see it in
people who are we see heightened levels
of exercise energy compensation among
people who are in negative energy
balance or people who are in a caloric
deficit and then the third factor that
seems to be popping up in the literature
that predicts an individual's level of
compensation is BMI but we need some
more research before we can actually
act upon this observation so when we
look at observational studies we can see
that compensation values typically tend
to be higher in people who have higher
bmis and higher body fat percentages but
we really don't know why and we don't
really know the direction of causation
so we don't know if people get to a high
BMI because they have high levels of
exercise energy compensation or if it's
the other way around where people start
to experience higher levels of exercise
energy compensation because they've
gotten to a higher BMI until we can
start to parse out the causative links
that are underlying these observations
there's not much we can do with the
observations other than observe them and
simply acknowledge them so compensation
levels do seem to be higher in people
with higher bmis but we do not know so
which event precedes the other and we
don't necessarily know if one causes the
other there could be a completely uh
there could be a completely separate
factor that is explaining this
relationship such that neither of those
things is causing the other it can be a
much more complicated scenario with
other factors that are at play so for
now we don't really know how to use that
BMI observation in my opinion but it is
worth noting
so all this stuff is good uh you know
this all makes sense we've talked about
uh the the the ways in which cardio can
impact fat loss and weight management
but a good question is how you would
actually go about applying this right so
what I mean by that is if you're trying
to facilitate fat loss
um you know what you really want to do
is figure out how
a particular change in exercise will
actually impact your energy deficit you
know that we're trying to manipulate the
energy deficit so that we can facilitate
fat loss and in order to do that you
know we basically need to figure out how
we can truly estimate how much a
specific exercise bout is going to
increase total daily energy expenditure
that is how we start to piece this
together and figure out how to
manipulate an energy deficit using
exercise we have to figure out how much
will this exercise increase my total
daily energy expenditure and then we
have to figure out what is my total
daily energy intake and how do I
manipulate the two to create the size of
energy deficit that I need to facilitate
my weight loss goal now there are some
challenges here uh it is hard to get
good information about the energy cost
of a given exercise bout there are so
many factors at play when you talk about
something as simple as walking you know
how many calories do you burn walking
well it depends how quickly are you
walking are you walking uphill or
downhill when you start to look at an
exercise bout and trying to quantify the
total energy cost there are a lot of
factors and a lot of details that go
into it which makes it hard to just use
generalizable values another issue
is as we've discussed you need to come
you need to basically estimate your
likely compensation value when it comes
to exercise energy compensation and you
need to account for that in the estimate
so we could determine that on average or
we could determine that a particular
exercise bout is supposed to increase
your energy expenditure by 100 calories
but for some people it's going to
increase by 90 for others it's going to
increase by 50 because of this exercise
energy compensation we need to estimate
your individualized most likely
compensation level and then factor that
into the mathematics and then finally
if we're trying to see how an exercise
bout
is going to increase total daily energy
expenditure we need to frame this
calculation relative to our resting
energy expenditure which of course needs
to be an individualized estimate uh the
reason being when you do an hour of
physical activity that's not truly just
an added value to your energy
expenditure you are doing an hour of
physical activity and you are
subtracting an hour of rest and so you
need to account for the fact that you
are doing physical activity instead of
an alternative reality where you were
resting for that same amount of time so
as we're we're running through the
numbers and trying to figure out how an
exercise bout is going to impact our
energy deficit and our total daily
energy expenditure we need to combine
all these different factors what does my
resting energy expenditure what is the
energy cost of the bout typically and
then how will my perceived uh you know
most likely compensation value actually
impact all of you know this in entire
estimate so that's a lot of work to do
that is a lot of digging around and
finding things and doing calculations
and so for that reason uh the macro
Factor team made a calculator that does
all of this for you and so I'm going to
link that in the the show notes for
today's episode
all you need to do is follow the link
enter some very very basic information
about yourself your intended exercise
bout and the calculator takes over from
there it has uh it's already pre-loaded
with a really robust selection of
different types of exercise at different
intensities and so if you use the
exercise calorie calculator I think
you'll find that it's very very
comprehensive and it does give a very
individualized estimate of you know for
your body and the information you
entered for the exercise bout that
you're planning to do here is our best
estimate of how much it's going to
increase your total daily energy
expenditure and we also give a range so
we say here's our best estimate but it's
probably going to be somewhere between
value X and value y so moving forward uh
when we talk about cardio there's one
common question that I think really
needs to be addressed
and that is
um should I be doing like what intensity
level should I be doing should I be
doing Sprint interval training high
intensity interval training moderate
intensity steady state low intensity
steady state we talked about all these
different types of structured cardio and
the short answer is for body comp it
probably doesn't matter so
there's a really excellent uh
meta-analysis by James Steele and his
research group where they were looking
at the effects of higher versus lower
intensity approaches to cardio and how
they impacted uh both fat mass and
fat-free Mass what they found was that
neither form of cardio led to
substantially Better or Worse changes in
body composition both of them led to
pretty modest increases in fat-free mass
and pretty modest reductions in fat Mass
again
of course the effects would be much
larger if you paired it with a specific
diet intervention but as we've stated
previously cardio on its own unlikely to
make really dramatic changes in body
composition unless you're doing a pretty
tremendous amount when we look at most
of the studies uh comparing high and
lower lower intensity uh approaches to
cardio they tend to have similar effects
on body composition and the effects
generally are pretty modest unless
you're combining it with some type of
dietary intervention so when it comes to
choosing between interval training
versus continuous exercise high
intensity versus low intensity you
really want to let your preference guide
that decision there's no right or wrong
answer there and I know that there might
be some skepticism when you hear that
it's very possible
that you've heard some pretty
extraordinary claims about
high-intensity interval training so for
example you might have heard that high
intensity interval training is better
for lowering mortality risk or that it
will double your endurance performance
after only 15 minutes of training for
two weeks at a time
um you know you might have heard that
one minute of this high intensity
interval training is equivalent to 45
minutes of moderate intensity steady
state exercise you might have heard that
this interval training is more enjoyable
more pleasant or that it leads to longer
term adherence when you compare it to
lower intensity steady state
Alternatives
um
because of all these uh common claims
that that really make a big splash uh
when they get shared by news outlets I
wanted to bring some attention to a
really Illuminating really fascinating
article series by echococcus and
colleagues I hope I'm pronouncing that
last name correctly but Dr ekakis I was
corresponding with him recently about
this work and it's a really from what
I've seen it is a really tremendous it's
a six-part article series of
peer-reviewed scientific articles so far
part two and part four have been
published in journals and the other
parts of what I believe is a six-part
series uh should be getting published in
the near future so uh Parts two and four
uh collectively basically debunk all the
claims that I just ran through and they
do it in a way that is very rigorous
very thorough frankly very impressive
from from the perspective of someone who
critiques research on a regular basis uh
this article series by ekakis echocus
and colleagues uh so far I've seen Parts
two and four very impressive and does a
lot of great work in debunking some of
these common myths and misconceptions
and uh exaggerations about high
intensity exercise now
I want to be super clear
this does not mean that high intensity
interval training or that Sprint
interval training is bad or useless or
that it's a scam or anything like that
this is a very very effective form of
exercise the reason that there's a need
for this six-part article series
is because some of the claims about
interval training have become overblown
you know when you see some of these
claims you look at them and say why in
the world would anyone be doing steady
state exercise it looks like this
interval training with higher intensity
is just so much better across every
possible domain uh and and a lot of
those claims are are pretty severe
exaggerations when we look at a a very
thorough comparison of high intensity
interval type cardio interventions
versus moderate intensity or low
intensity steady state cardio
interventions
the really reassuring thing is that both
of them seem to be excellent but it
would be incorrect to suggest that one
is dramatically better than the other
across the board and so what that means
is there is so much room uh so much
wiggle room so that you can experiment
with both approaches and let your
preference guide the way you can see uh
you know which one do I prefer which one
do do I enjoy more which one fits my
schedule better
um you know you you have a lot of
opportunities to do some guess in check
figure out which approach to cardio
works best for you and ultimately
whichever one you go with you're
probably going to be ending up in the
same place whether you go with higher
intensity or lower intensity as long as
you're matching the total amount of of
effort and work now
one caveat for that uh overview is of
course if you are trying to do cardio
not for health and fitness you know not
for just General Wellness not for weight
management if you're trying to do cardio
to specifically improve your performance
in a particular sport or you're trying
to develop a very specific uh
physiological capacity if you want to
get better at repeated Sprint activity
or you want to do better at Ultra
marathons if you're trying to improve a
specific physical capacity related to a
specific sport uh you need to make sure
that you're tailoring your cardio to
address the actual adaptations you're
trying to induce so it's a very very
different world when you're talking
about cardio type exercise for sport
applications you have to be quite
specific when you're planning out your
training for that purpose but when it
comes to General Health General Wellness
weight management high intensity low
intensity interval steady state you have
a lot of flexibility to choose whatever
fits your preference
now the final thing I want to mention
when we're talking about cardio is one
last question we've talked about it on
the show before but a question that
comes up a lot is cardio going to kill
my gains and the short answer you know
just to to frame the conversation is
probably not a lot of people who are
really into lifting are very hesitant to
add any type of physical activity or
cardio in addition to their lifting
because they've heard about the
interference effect that comes with
concurrent training so when we say
concurrent training we're going to
operationally Define that as a training
program that includes both resistance
training and cardio training
concurrently within the same program so
it's a program that includes some of
both rather than saying I only lift or I
only do cardio and when we talk about
the interference effect we're going to
discuss it from the perspective of a
lifter or a lifting Enthusiast so people
who are really into lifting are worried
that adding cardio is going to interfere
with their lifting related training
adaptations so they're lifting because
they want to get more powerful they want
to get stronger they want to increase
their lean body mass you know they want
to induce muscular hypertrophy and there
is some degree of concern among many
lifters that if they do some additional
cardio it is going to interfere with
those resistance training adaptations so
with that in mind I want to just
reiterate that these concerns in most
cases are very much overblown and
exaggerated in most cases the typical
lifter really doesn't need to worry
about it much at all
and there are three important reminders
here when it comes to the interference
effect and concurrent training first of
all the interference affect even when
it's demonstrated in studies it impacts
different training adaptations to
different magnitudes so the interference
effect impacts power much more that that
it impacts strength or hypertrophy you
can put them in order the impact on
power
is by far the greatest in terms of the
interference effect the impact on
strength is is quite minimal and the
impact on hypertrophy is even more
minimal so most folks that are
interested in strength and hypertrophy
already you can look at the research and
say probably don't need to be very
concerned about the interference effect
uh another thing that's worth uh you
know a second reminder is that recent
meta-analyzes are reporting much smaller
effects than some of the early studies
about the interference effect
and that's because the early studies
were basically designed to try to
identify the largest effect possible you
know if you believe this exists but it
has not yet been shown or demonstrated
you want to design a study that
exaggerates the potential impact as we
look at more studies that are more
feasible more real-world applications of
concurrent training or training programs
with a lifting component and a cardio
component unless you're trying to induce
the interference effect by going really
overboard what we see is that the
interference effect seems to be very
very modest in the more recent studies
and the meta-analyzes are showing that
in most cases it really probably
shouldn't be a major pressing concern
and I mean just a very this is not a
rigorous scientific take but if you're
really worried about adding in a little
bit of cardio think about the amount of
time that a professional American
football player spends on their feet
doing what we would call endurance type
or cardio type training when they're on
the field playing their sport they are
doing some combination of intensity
levels uh in ambulatory exercise and so
you would not look at the roster of an
NFL football team and say man it's
really tragic that all the time on your
feet doing physical activity has caused
this extreme degree of muscle wasting I
mean these are remarkably strong
remarkably powerful remarkably muscular
athletes uh generally speaking and so
that even though it's not a rigorous
scientific take it should alleviate some
of our worst fears about how much adding
a you know an hour or two of cardio a
week might impact our resistance
training adaptations
and then finally when we talk about the
interference effect with cardio the key
word is too much cardio or I guess the
two keywords too much uh most folks in
the context of a feasible real world
concurrent training program really are
not doing enough cardio to meaningfully
and meaningfully attenuate their
resistance training gains especially
when it comes to strength and
hypertrophy if you participate in a
sport where power is the top priority
then I think it does make sense to take
a closer look at what you're doing for
cardio to make sure that you're not
going to induce any type of interference
there but if you're focused on strength
and Hyper strength and hypertrophy the
likelihood that you're doing enough
cardio to meaningfully impact your
adaptations is pretty low so for most
people the interference effect probably
shouldn't be a huge concern but there
are some scenarios where it's a more
pertinent consideration and these were
outlined by Greg in one of his Mass
articles within the last couple years
he's been doing a great job in Mass
staying on top of this concurrent
training literature uh number one if
your capacity to recover from training
is really diminished at the moment you
might want to take a close look at your
total volume of you know both resistance
training and cardio type training and
just make sure that you're not
overwhelming your body your body's
capacity to recover in general right so
it's not that cardio in this context
isn't necessarily bad it's that if you
are in a state where your overall
recovery capacity is diminished due to
things like poor sleep high level of
stress large caloric deficit in those
scenarios you already have diminished
recovery capacity so you just want to
make sure that your total amount of
exercise is not completely overwhelming
number two if you're doing so much
cardio training that you're already you
know stressing your recovery capacity to
a near maximal level of course you're
going to struggle to add in a meaningful
amount of resistance training and that's
something that has to be navigated uh
very thoughtfully and the inverse is
true as well if you're already doing so
much resistance training that you can
barely recover from your lifting uh
obviously you have to be very thoughtful
about how you try to incorporate any
additional cardio training beyond that
and again that doesn't mean cardio
training is necessarily bad it means
you're already training to a point where
your recovery capacity is essentially
maxed out and so whether you wanted to
ramp up your lifting or add in extra
cardio that's something that you're
going to have to address uh really
really thoughtfully and then again just
to reiterate if your primary goal for
doing exercise in general is to maximize
power output so really explosive power
then you might want to take a close look
at how you're incorporating cardio but
if your main goal is strength or
hypertrophy uh you're probably it's
probably very unlikely that you're going
to be inducing a massive interference
effect by just doing enough cardio to
facilitate fat loss or to facilitate
General Health and Wellness now if
you're going to be doing concurrent
training
and you want to take
every possible precaution to minimize
the potential impact on your your
resistance training adaptations there
are some best practices that you can
follow so first of all you want to avoid
an excessive volume of just total
exercise training like I said whether
it's cardio or lifting you just want to
make sure that you're not throwing your
body more than it can handle in terms of
recovery capacity another step you can
take is when possible you could put your
cardio sessions on your non-lifting days
just trying to separate those things out
now that's not always going to be
feasible depending on your training
frequency and your schedule so when
that's not feasible the next best thing
you can do is try to do your cardio in a
separate session on the same day so you
could have two training sessions on the
same day but try to separate them by at
least six hours so you could lift in the
morning do your cardio go in the evening
it's not quite as good as doing sessions
on separate days but it's it's pretty
close and then there will be some
situations where it's just not feasible
to do cardio and lifting on separate
days it's not feasible to separate them
into different sessions and when that's
the case
um
if you're a lifting Enthusiast who
prioritizes your resistance training
adaptations if you have to do these
sessions or these these two different
types of exercise within the same
session I would recommend doing your
resistance training first and then
finishing the session with your cardio
training uh another thing you can do to
prevent just kind of totally overloading
your capacity for Recovery is if you're
doing concurrent training you might want
to think very uh thoughtfully about how
much super high intensity work that
you're doing a lot of folks tend to
report and there's some research to
verify that there is kind of an
amplified recovery burden when we're
doing really intense interval training
so high intensity interval training
Sprint interval training it can take a
minute to recover from that sometimes it
takes you 24 48 hours before you feel
like you can get back into the gym and
really give it your best in terms of
your next resistance training about so
what I usually like to do
if I'm trying to just be as cautious as
possible and as proactive as possible to
prevent the likelihood of an
interference effect is I will limit the
total number of high intensity cardio
sessions to no more than three per week
and if I need to do more cardio than
that for you know General Health and
Wellness purposes or for fat loss
purposes what I will do is then you know
once I've maxed out my limit for high
intensity sessions at three per week if
I need to do more cardio I'll just
incorporate some lower intensity forms
of steady state cardio when possible
kind of along the same lines
if I'm going to be doing a high
intensity cardio about so if I'm doing
like Sprint interval training on the
bike I'm sprinting with my lower body
musculature there I will try to schedule
my next leg day for resistance training
at least 24 to 48 hours later and the
later the better in terms of just giving
that musculature the opportunity to
recover before you're jumping into
another uh pretty vigorous resistance
training session so if I'm running
Sprints or doing cycling Sprints I'm
doing sprints with my lower body
musculature I try to make sure my next
leg day
ideally is at least 48 hours apart but
if it has to be 24 sometimes you know so
be it but but I try to space that out to
the best of my ability and then the
final thing you want to do is just
adhere to some basic guidelines for the
intensity and the duration of your
cardio sessions
uh so for example
I already mentioned that the easiest way
to quantify intensity with these
different types of cardio is to look at
the heart rate range framed as a
percentage of maximum heart rate
and what we're going to do is treat
these different types of cardio sessions
as relatively interchangeable we're just
going to look at one unit of cardio
based on its intensity and its duration
so for one unit of cardio throughout the
week we could use low intensity steady
state which would be 50 to 69 percent of
Max heart rate and a duration of
somewhere between 30 to 60 minutes
that's kind of what I would call a unit
of low intensity steady state and of
course these are basic guidelines
General heuristics don't get too bogged
down in the details this is just to kind
of help people
if you're going to be arranging this
puzzle of how you're fitting and mixing
and matching different types of cardio I
think it's helpful to get a basic
understanding of what the puzzle pieces
look like individually
so low intensity steady state
50 to 69 percent of Max heart rate 30 to
60 Minutes in total duration of that
training session moderate intensity
steady state we're going to be doing 70
to 84 percent of Max heart rate and the
total duration of that training session
will probably be somewhere between 20 to
45 minutes
high intensity interval training heart
rate uh when we're reaching our kind of
elevated Peak heart rate during those
work intervals that's going to be
getting up to around to at least 85
percent of Max heart rate the total
duration of a high intensity interval
session for me usually going to last
between 15 to 25 minutes in total
and that means we're including the work
interval intervals and the rest
intervals in that total duration and
with high intensity interval training I
usually have my work to rest ratio
somewhere around one to one you know so
I might do a minute of work and a minute
of rest or I might do 30 seconds of work
and 30 seconds of rest but there's some
fluctuation there there's some
variability sometimes I'll do one unit
of work to two two units of rest so I
might do a one minute Sprint or a one
minute high intensity interval and then
two minutes of rest uh so the work to
work to rest ratio usually going to be
around one to one but sometimes you know
might be a little bit different you can
work around that General range and and
find something that works for you and
then finally Sprint interval training
this is going to be the work intervals
are just maximal intensity so heart rate
certainly should be getting up to
greater than 85 percent of maximum heart
rate again the duration is in total
gonna be about 15 to 25 minutes in most
cases but that includes the work to uh
that includes both the work intervals
and the rest intervals and the duration
is the same when we talk about Sprint
interval training and high intensity
interval training but the work to rest
ratio tends to be different so like I
said
high intensity interval training is not
necessarily maximal intensity so you can
get away with a work to rest ratio
that's only one to one but if we're
doing Sprint interval training we see
that we we start to skew the work to
rest ratio we need to rest longer in
order to actually do these work
intervals at a maximal intensity so
usually I'll do one unit of work to
maybe three units of rest or sometimes
up to eight units of rest so the work to
rest ratio could be one to three or it
could even get up to one to eight in
terms of how we are talking about the
relative duration of our work interval
versus our rest interval so the total
duration of the session tends to be
similar when we compare Sprint interval
training to high intensity interval
training but I usually have more a
longer rest ratio
relative to the work ratio there are a
lot longer rest interval relative to the
work interval when I'm doing Sprint
interval training so wrapping up here in
conclusion cardio and general physical
activity is great for overall health and
wellness whether you're doing structured
exercise or not exercise physical
activity in both cases this stuff that
falls under the the umbrella of physical
activity is really really great for
overall health and wellness uh cardio
and physical activity can facilitate an
energy deficit by increasing total daily
energy expenditure however
that increase is usually only about 50
to 90 percent as large as you would
mathematically predict because of
exercise energy compensation so cardio
can help with fat loss but it usually
has a smaller impact than you would
expect it usually only yields 20 to 50
percent of the fat loss that you would
mathematically predict uh part of that
is because of exercise energy
compensation and part of that is due to
changes in appetite and energy intake
which of course we can control and
attenuate if we do our cardio
intervention in conjunction with a
calorie restricted diet or some type of
structured diet intervention
now I I don't want to suggest that
cardio always causes an increase in
energy intake because like I said
previously
cardio can actually improve and enhance
appetite regulation for people who are
relatively sedentary at Baseline uh so
for someone who's really sedentary at
Baseline uh you know incorporating
cardio as part of a weight loss strategy
is a really good idea for helping uh
kind of recalibrate appetite to their
energy expenditure level and as I
mentioned previously physical activity
is a very reliable predictor of
long-term weight loss success so
appetite stuff aside it does seem that
as a general approach to weight loss it
is a pretty good idea to incorporate a
relatively high level of physical
activity whether that's coming from
non-exercise physical activity or coming
from structured cardio a couple things
uh you know something that people worry
about a lot that they probably shouldn't
worry about as much just to reiterate a
lot of folks tend to worry that if they
add some cardio it's going to totally
kill their resistance training gains
that concern is largely overblown and
the the requirement to really worry
about the interference effect is
restricted to some pretty specific
scenarios and applications for most
folks who are doing a feasible program
that they can work into their day-to-day
life and for folks who are focused on
strength and hypertrophy specifically
the interference effect as it pertains
to concurrent training probably not
something that you have to worry about
too much and then once again if you're
going to add cardio
uh whether it's for health purposes or
for weight management purposes you can
add whatever type you prefer whatever
type of cardio you like so uh in the
broadest sense whether you do
non-exercise physical activity or
structured cardio again totally up to
you if you are going to do structured
cardio then you're choosing between all
different types of interval training and
steady state training overall high
intensity interval training Sprint
interval training is not you know
consistently Better or Worse across the
board when we compare it to lower
intensity forms of steady state cardio
so you have a tremendous amount of
flexibility to find an approach to
cardio that works for you
and now finally
um
before I end this episode I hope you'll
afford me once again the opportunity to
make a Shameless sales pitch for macro
factor which is the diet app that Greg
and I co-developed with an incredible
team of talented colleagues as you
consider the wide variety of diet
approaches and strategies and weight
management strategies that you might
Implement in the New Year rest assured
macro Factor can facilitate whatever
you're planning to do first and foremost
it is a very fast very efficient and
very convenient food logger it has a
huge verified database of foods and it
also has very easy and efficient
workflows to create custom Foods create
custom recipes and even share those
recipes with your friends and family so
whatever your food Choice preferences
are macro Factor can definitely handle
it in addition you know we talked a lot
about energy expenditure and and cardio
and weight loss in today's episode one
thing that a lot of people struggle with
is trying to incorporate cardio into
their dietary program for the purpose of
supporting weight loss the macro Factor
Diet app is really unique in the way
that it can support different levels of
physical activity and the real magic
behind it is the fact that macro Factor
has a very robust energy expenditure
algorithm so as you're using macro
Factor it is constantly using the data
you provide in terms of your body weight
and body composition in addition to your
nutritional intakes the energy
expenditure algorithm is constantly
reassessing and recalibrating its
understanding of your daily energy
expenditure and what you'll see is by
using this kind of backward looking
deterministic expenditure algorithm
macro factor is really well equipped to
help you incorporate cardio and physical
activity into your diet program for
weight loss in the new year so in
summary a macro factor is your diet
sidekick it provides all the guidance
all the support all the analytics that
you need as you pursue your fitness
goals in the new year without infringing
on your ability to make your own
decisions and to chart your own course
toward your fitness goals so to learn
more go ahead and check out the app at
macrofactorapp.com or you can find it in
the app stores as always thank you for
joining me for another episode of The
Stronger by science podcast we'll be
back soon with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]